next 2019 included so many great
sessions it is likely you missed a few
or wanted to relive some of your
favorites
my friend Seth Vargo gave an awesome
talk about DevOps versus sre are they
competing standards or friends join me
for a spoiler free preview of Seth's
presentation developers are told to
build and ship features faster operators
are told to keep the system stable and
reliable this creates an environment
with misaligned incentives this
misalignment encourages developers to
throw changes over the proverbial wall
as fast as possible while encouraging
operators to reject those changes in
pursuit of stability and reliability
shipping faster and running more
reliable systems are great objectives
but the DevOps movement is about more
than that it's about aligning everyone
to improve the customer experience there
are a number of DevOps practices that we
can put in place to help let's take a
quick look at some of them first up is
the idea that we should reduce
organizational silos developers and
operators working together are more
capable of delivering the best results
we all want to live in a world where our
systems are 100% available reliable and
perform it we also know that this land
of unicorns and lollipops does not
actually exist
DevOps implores us to accept failure as
a normal mode of operation something we
can do to improve both speed and safety
is implement and introduce changes
gradually to playing a small change that
was made is much safer than deploying a
large change that was made and has been
building up over a number of weeks or
even months another practice of DevOps
is leveraging tooling and automation
whether provisioning systems deploying
applications or patching the operating
system there is a place for good
automation practices making these tasks
easy and automatic frees up developers
operators and others to focus on more
important work finally DevOps teaches us
that
need to measure everything having good
metrics and measurements about our
systems helps us make good decisions
about how to improve those systems
without good metrics how will we know if
our changes were impactful so those are
some of the DevOps practices what
exactly is sre well in 2016
Google together with O'Reilly released a
book on the topic of site reliability
engineering the ideas presented in the
book have led some to ask the question
that is central to this talk our DevOps
and sre competitors or friends one
concept that sre introduces is the error
budget it helps the business make
trade-offs between speed and reliability
the error budget informs what to do when
the system is not meeting its
reliability goals for example the error
budget may dictate that teams stop
pushing new features and focus all
engineering efforts on the things that
make the system more reliable like
automated deployments sre provides a
framework for defining these error
budgets we start with service level
indicators or SL eyes an SLI is a metric
that tells us something about the system
the best SL eyes are the ones that give
us an indication of customer happiness
so for example a customer will be happy
when their shopping cart loads correctly
and unhappy when it loses items from the
SL eyes we can now generate some service
level objectives or SLO s an SLO lets us
set a goal for an acceptable level of
service reliability over time for
example we might say that 99.99% of
requests to the shopping cart over the
past 28 days should be successful so
DevOps and SRE
are they competing standards or friends
well I promised not to spoil it for you
so check out the link in the description
below to find out the answer or draw
your own conclusions and while you're
there be sure to subscribe to the Google
cloud YouTube channel for more great
next rewind content thanks for watching
[Music]